hey twig
come here
oh man what did they do to you
hey you want to help us get out of here
um
there's something I need you to get and
bring back to me
in the Captain's Quarters there's a
prototype fin
the thing I wore in my head there's a
drawer next to the bunk it's in that
it's red you got it
good
[Music]
morning
the
that's my underwears yeah I was pretty
sure he didn't know what you were
talking about you have to explain it
more careful
it's a prototype fin
that's an orlonian it's a fan group
we'll explain it this time
all right
that's vorkor's eye he takes it out when
he sleeps go look again but leave the
eye here
why he's gonna wake up tomorrow
it's not gonna know where his eye is
a desk
we told you it was this big
[Music]
tell me you guys have a refrigerator
somewhere with a bunch of seven human
toes
okay then let's just agree to never
discuss this
[Music]
drawer you want to open
has this symbol on it okay
[Music]
what no he thinks you want him to wear
it as a hat that's not what I said he's
relieved you don't want him though he
hates heads on anyone not just himself
one minute you think someone has a weird
shaped head the next minute just because
you realize part of that head is the Hat
that's why you don't like hats
this is an important conversation right
now
[Music]
laughs
that ain't it
foreign